all right welcome everybody it is monday
i am
back i did not do any streaming over the
weekend but we are back very powerfully
i have memes i have videos i have images
i have super chats i have
messages i have insults and voicemails
and so many different things so i'm glad
to have some time
uh to go over all of this stuff with you
guys the main event scheduled originally
for a half hour ago
then rescheduled for a half hour from
now is donald trump at a magar
rally that's how we're calling the magar
in uh
tucson arizona spoke in phoenix arizona
um just about finishing about a half
hour ago
and on his way to tucson and we were
expecting him roughly at the top of the
hour i do have a new song to play for
you guys
uh really a custom creation based on
your demands i would call them if i
if i may uh so we have so many different
things to talk about hype trains are
flying super chats are flying
memberships are ooh not
flying but that's okay that's okay still
early
um where to even start let me start just
with one small element
as many of you know i take the streams
very seriously i just don't show up here
and stream with no plan i can't
imagine there are any degenerate
streamers that would do that i respect
all of you way too much to just show up
so right now i have about 12 different
browser elements open
one meme two songs five
super chats and then as a backup i have
uh prepper stories and different things
actually let me do my prepper story
first um you if you were a member you
would already have heard this on the
bonus show today
but if you're not i'll tell the story
right now anyway because it's a good one
as many of you know when coronavirus
started i started some light prepping
including some water storage i got i had
a
my water browned out a few months ago i
had brown water which uh
i was they told me not to drink and you
know all this stuff i had to boil it and
all
of these different things so i got these
two 15 gallon
cubes of water thick plastic did my
research
as far as i knew got the right stuff and
last night getting ready to go to bed
and i go to fill my brita
which is white it's bone white actually
bone is not totally white it's comple
it's synthetic white
and anything other than clear water
really shows up
and i've got yellow water coming out so
i say
beautiful i've got my water prepped so
you know i call the sewer commission and
i say i've got brown water
and they say we know about it we're
working on it don't drink it for the
time being
so i go you know into my garage and i
get a mason jar full of my water it's
beautifully clear
it smells a little bit plasticky i'm not
going to lie but from what i read it's
not actually plastic leeching in it's
just a bit of a smell
i hope that's true and i hand it to my
girlfriend she goes to brush her teeth
and then i
i hear something weird and then she
comes down and says
there's a worm in the water i say worm
how the hell can there be a worm in the
water the plastic things are completely
sealed and
um i go up and i it was so little
i couldn't tell if it was some kind of
parasite a worm or a piece of plastic i
really couldn't
threw it out and then clearly my water
prep was done wrong people asking
if i first rinsed the things fully
i did not i did not and apparently that
was that was a mistake so
i guess which if somebody who preps can
tell me what to do
please email me through my website and
tell me like should i just throw out the
30 gallons
and then that'll be considered the rinse
and then just start over
what the hell should i do okay so let's
uh that that was my excited prepping
gone wrong
clearly thanks to camilla wahlberg
camilla is new member number one today
at joinedpakman.com i'll consider that
membership
a tip for my water storage
story um okay people wanted me to review
this is joe buck and troy aikman during
a flyover
and apparently there's something
political here and people can't tell
what let's uh let me just take a listen
to it
jet fuel just to do a little fly over
that's your hard-earned money and your
tax dollars at work
that stuff ain't happening with kamala
biden ticket i'll tell you that right
now
uh so you know if i hear that what i
hear
is this is such a stupid waste of your
taxpayer money to waste fuel
and pollute to have these planes fly
over however
i don't know that that's what joe buck
and troy aikman mean
and uh that is that is pretty
significant cringe yeah that's
that's off the cringe scale if you ask
me so
to me it should be that it
that should be if they were in their
right minds that should be a left-wing
comment
but my instinct is that that was troy
aikman making an
anti-biden comment that's my sense what
do people think
am i reading that correctly that's
certainly my instinct
people tend to agree with me okay yeah
that's fair
that's fair all right very good so we
got that out of the way
um i don't want to do memes yet because
some of the memes are really really
strong
so i want to wait on them so as many
people as possible see it we only have
one stream in the room right now
and that is right side broadcasting i
try to avoid them
but it does show us that trump has not
yet arrived
let me read a few super chats here
marianne says about today's show sadly
in germany their dr
fauci kristen drosten has also received
death threats
that's not good chakaseki wants a shout
out for dave
garzowski and ben in somerville repping
their awesome beer company
fab love it big shout out sinful
says convalescent plasma love it
sam says david big fan i'm nervous once
trump leaves either this year or in 2024
people will forget how awful he is sort
of like bush
yeah i worry about the same chuck says
what up david big fan thank you for
doing what you do any chance my daughter
israel can get a birthday shout out
please yes
israel happy birthday
congratulations love it johnny says i
loved friday's show as it had more
costume changes than a share concert
anyway thoughts on question 2 and mass
on ranked choice
i'm voting yes
on question 2 in massachusetts oh by the
way
if you follow me on instagram you would
know this already
but i posted very powerful video of me
voting over the weekend
here it is with audio dropping in
and then with the robotic thumbs up and
then just walking right off screen
that's my
vote and you know what's really
frustrating
i got at first it was like 50 i ended up
getting about 100 messages from people
saying david
that doesn't look like a mailbox you
just got
tricked that's a fake usps
mailbox and of course it's not a mailbox
that is one of six or seven
official city of boston ballot drop
boxes
i drove by today and saw the election
commission
emptying it out with security around
them
hello so no i i it was like
i was cringing that so many people
thought i would just think that's a
mailbox
it is an official city of boston dropbox
very very good
um and then also if you followed me on
instagram which you really should
you'd know about my tomato bounty
extremely strong tomato bounty
you would already know about this
voicemail i got your little argentine
israeli troll and why aren't you wearing
a mask
you do this live stream all your shows i
never see you
you wear a [ __ ] mask uh
when you're doing your live streams you
know so why are you wearing goggles why
why don't you have headphones on and and
a necklace when
all that money you make you don't have
an old gold necklace
how come you don't have a gold tooth
like uh [ __ ]
uh flavor flav you know
you're a hypocrite if you can complain
about people taking their masters off at
a rally you think they're
all supposed to wear masks then you mask
up and you put one on your [ __ ] ugly
face
yeah i mean it's like why am i not
wearing a mask when sitting here by
myself
oh look the great anna rudolph the chess
streamer
with a beautiful comment what an
excellent piece of respectful
constructive feedback very very nice
very very nice comment there uh from
anna
that was a perfect phone call my friend
so anyway if you're interested in that
type of thing and i know that some of
you are not
um you you can follow me on instagram
for that sort of thing
okay let's let's go over to twitch
things are happening on twitch big thank
you to r
rhino for the 10 month sub timothy
stacy nichols scoopy peterson
jerry mandering jajashi
beta tribus the strawberry rodeo
and uh mig who else
the wilhelm screen oh that's from three
days ago hold on i mean
okay i don't take it back but that was
not from this stream
also thanks to ronald roth ronald roth
is new member number
two at joinpackman.com
other super chats inconsolable says five
gib
gifted subs if you tell okay here we go
if you tell the terrible leftists on
your subreddit
in no uncertain terms where you stand on
bolivia
so that they can stop spamming their
nonsense oh i don't even know
what's going on i saw one post um
where i stand on bolivia um
i mean listen i think bolivia should
determine for themselves who should lead
the country
without any foreign meddling of any kind
and if i see hijinks
internally in bolivia i'll call it like
i see it i mean i guess that's it i
don't know i don't know what else to say
i don't know if that's worthy of five
gifted subs but
that's uh that's where my mind is right
now on the issue
derek says did you see that nature and
the new england medical journal came out
against trump it was epic
i did see that and that was very
interesting
ken clive says trump for rikers island
2020 don't let him leave the u.s after
he loses
indeed oh there's the five gifted subs
from i'm inconsolable over on twitch i
love it
uh unknown prodigy don't think what's
the first reason that comes to your mind
why you would never vote for trump
authoritarian maniac that indian dude
says hey david thoughts on europe's
disastrous second wave well listen
uh we are already on to wave three
if you think the seq the europe sequel
is bad
wait until you see the third installment
in the united states i think it's going
to be
uh an absolute train wreck here dalton
haskins says hey david i just early
voted in
soflo south florida and turnout was huge
question if trump wins with biden
maintaining a steady lead in the polls
do we change the way we look at polls
going forward
yes we do yes we do absolutely
um jack dixon says
hassan is going to be playing the game
among us with aoc
you should join them oh is that right
that's interesting let me see
i jokingly responded when she tweeted
you know that i'll play i've never even
played the game i mean
whoa sorry i should have silenced my
phone there
that's very rude of me um
let's see aoc getting
set up interesting
how do we know hasan is playing i would
even be interested in washing
watching that hassan see what's going on
here
just trying to find some stuff
hassan i don't even know how to find
hassan's twitter
this is crazy oh here it is hassan the
son okay
he has a message to his haters
what else does he have
already making a lobby
i don't know anyway i have no idea
what's going on
they've been having a back and forth
okay
yeah all right anyway i can't find i'm
sure you guys are telling me the truth
nobody in chat has ever lied to me
but uh i i'm having trouble following uh
following the entire thing
okay we are potentially just a few
minutes from donald trump's arrival i
think via the chopper
in uh tucson arizona and things are
going to be uh things are going to be
going on there
let me see what else we've got here momo
symphonia says hi from tucson it's 95
degrees here i wonder if trump forgot
about that when choosing to rally at
this time of day
yeah it will be interesting to see how
sweaty he is do you have an opinion on
the
uk's new labor leader kier starner no i
don't
i i'm not in a position to comment yet
james aleppo says azanpago
love the show david i don't know what
language that is
sir worthington says hey david what are
your thoughts on the us debt where
does this end up to 27 trillion from
obama's 19 trillion
that's a big topic check out my
interviews about modern monetary theory
and the political football
that is um uh debt and deficit
there's a lot there um
christy says this is my donation towards
your gold chain yeah that caller who
asked why i'm not wearing a gold chain
i'm just not a jewelry guy i don't know
what it has to do with wearing masks
very weird edward blackman says our dog
mr miyagi loves your show keep up the
good work
please send video when people send
videos of their dogs
sometimes cats cats are a little bit you
know
colder on the show um but of their dogs
watching the show
that almost guarantees that the video
will get onto a stream at some point
um okay [ __ ] gordo says hey david do
you have pgp
to send you encrypted messages i don't
and honestly
every time someone has said i have
something i need to send you via an
encrypted message it's always been
worthless it's been like
nothing that you could just email me
there's no reason not to email me i've
never
i've never once had something where when
i go through the trouble trouble
of setting up signal because someone has
a scoop it's always like
literally worthless stuff i'm not saying
what you have is worthless [ __ ]
but um if you can explain
why you can't email me to tell me why
you can't email it let's start there you
know and then we'll we'll figure it out
the dude says trump is bringing his
corona tour
to town tomorrow i am getting my protest
sign
flush that turd november 3rd and mask
ready now
beautiful love that
um did you hear trump and company are
accusing whitmer of sending a cryptic
message out to assassinate trump i did
not see that
nina keitel bought the book white too
long
following my interview with the author
thanks i'm looking forward to reading
beautiful love that
uh big thank you to chad christopher
new member number three bobby johnson
new member number four
and riley myers new member number five
today
at joinpackman.com uh
i do have a few other things just
keeping an eye okay we now do have live
video from this event
we'll keep it here for the time being
and let's get over into hd always hd for
you guys never anything less
okay a couple other things here i do
have one
image to show you that someone made i
hope people won't find this offensive
and they'll understand the joke
um this was a beautiful beautiful meme
this is my prageru debut
debut as a gay jewish teen who was
bullied into suicide
go out and vote vote now this is fake
i didn't really do anything for prageru
this is a reference to when i was
featured in a documentary
uh where i was i guess promoted as
a gay teenager who um
died by suicide because i was bullied
and at the time i was 27 years old
i'm heterosexual and i was alive
at the time so it's just it's just a
reference to that we're not
you know diminishing the importance of
uh
homophobia preventing bullying or
suicide we're not doing any of that it's
just you know
it's just a little meme people put
together um another one is
david pakman's day off this is accurate
you're still here
go vote that's me and my bathrobe as you
can all tell
and um very very powerfully telling
people to go and vote
and on that note i have ready for you
guys
a debut song you guys asked for
uh david pakman show resident composer
joe woodward
to do a song related to when i was
interviewed by jessie lee peterson
okay joe woodward came through
and i indeed have that song ready for
you guys right now i was going to hold
this for the thursday night stream
during the debate
but i'm just going to to play it now
because it's really quite extraordinary
this is called ladies and gentlemen
david pakman
is a beta male by joseph woodward it's
really a story so you've got to stick
with it all right let's listen as we
wait for trump
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
host an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
right he is a baby
david packman he is a painter
david patman
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we we got it
that's a lot that's a lot of everything
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male died but a
knob
doesn't because it starts to build back
up
and then controlled by the darkness of
david pacman
he is a baby
david patman he is a baby
david pac-man too good he is
[Music]
he is
[Music]
david you're not here to communicate
this is where he kicked me off
i'm going to let you go it's a waste of
time to talk to you we're not
communicating
you're actually like because you're
asking bizarre questions you're actually
like
an idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right thank you for coming goodbye
goodbye
[Music]
so that is just an unbelievable new
release
from uh joseph woodward and what i think
i think the next
so hopefully joe will continue
developing
more more tracks this uh of course he is
the uh
the producer of the iconic plasma i
won't play at all but just as a reminder
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
okay anyway you guys get it i think the
next layer to this would be
that we go to anthony fantano
arguably the most well-known music
reviewer at this point in the united
states
and a friend of mine we go to fantano
and we ask
him to review these four tracks almost
like a mini album what would it be
called it's not an ep right
what what is it when it's like a four
song
album was there a name for that is that
an ep
i'm not even sure an lp okay anyway
we go to fantano and he reviews this
as if it's serious music which it is but
obviously the you know the lyrical
content is is completely outrageous
that i feel like would be you know we
keep it going so anyway
if people it's a demo tape of sorts yeah
it's a demo tape i would call it
so that's really really great stuff love
to see that and
uh just just really really great stuff
okay
let's continue with other things that i
have going on
um okay we did i'm trying to remember
what am i forgetting here um
oh corona yeah i mean i guess listen the
pandemic is back
very very strongly we had another 48 000
cases yesterday we're already up to 43
000 now and i'm predicting it's going to
get really bad
if you take a look at what's going on we
peaked to 32
000 and then some of our measures
started working so we got down to 20k
and then half the country said it open
up so then we peaked
to 70 000 a day and then summer came
more outdoor stuff
people taking things seriously and we
got back down to about 35k 35k we got
down to
then more stuff opened up and if you
look at this trajectory right now
we could be heading to 100 000 cases a
day
uh exactly the way dr anthony fauci
predicted so
that's what's going on there and i do
believe the death rate will be lower we
do have
some medications now that work it is on
average
younger people that work to some degree
the medications we do have slightly
younger people on average getting it
but we could very quickly be heading to
a hundred thousand cases a day
um and then as far as deaths go it's
basically flattened and now if you go
just the last few days now even the
seven day moving average
after being flat for a while is starting
to tick up so for people saying well
there's no the
there's no deaths there's cases but no
deaths i believe we are starting to see
the deaths uh
tick up so that is tragic it is it is
quite literally tragic
okay uh all right let's get back to
super chats oh
the new david pakman show discord which
we now use to take
phone calls it is fully launched over
the last 24 hours
some of our uh great moderators as well
as our
our administrator over on the discord
davidpakman.com
discord we are sprucing it up
it is properly moderated we're adding a
meme
section where it's it's a really great
place so
accept no substitute okay the only
official
david pakman show discord is
davidpakman.com
when i take phone calls it's through
there
and i think we've got about twenty one
hundred people
on that discord right now i would love
to get it to ten thousand
i would i'm just being very up front i
would love ten thousand we've got about
25 000 people on the subreddit these are
great community building places
that are they run 24 hours regardless of
whether i'm streaming or not
um so that is something i rush the
discord i'm inviting you to that
all right let's look at a few other
super chats here
oh opacity subscribed with prime with
the message
i love your fake news david keep it up
all right
thank you thank you patrice says
recently you mentioned that voting trump
in
leaves the door open for his kids to run
four years later
please keep this to the forefront of
people's minds i will try
i will try timothy villegiati
says what is your favorite type of bird
and how intelligent do you think birds
are
my favorite bird that's a good question
i think it's a raven and i think ravens
are very intelligent
very very intelligent highly trainable
deep pursley says mark kelly needs to
show up at trump's rally in a space suit
that would be that would be great
actually
i would love that um
more films says hey david love your show
big fan what's your take on the
republican party's move post-trump don
jr trump boot lockers
or traditional conservative video about
that
coming out friday okay on my friday show
i am addressing that
so i don't want to get ahead of myself
as my own press secretary
i don't want to get ahead of myself on
that topic but excellent question
classy andy says in ireland we're going
back into full lockdown for a month from
friday
the country isn't going to be as
supportive as last time yeah there's
fatigue
i get it there's fatigue tyler toomey
says david big fan would you consider
doing a layman's policy breakdown of
biden
from the standpoint of political much
love i've done it so i've got a video
about economic policy
i've got a video about clean energy i've
got a video about environment i've got a
video about taxation
most of those elements of political i
have reviewed already
carl says hey david i heard trump has
stock and the company's making the drugs
he was treated for kovid
how much money has he made off his
presidency you know
you're you're not wrong but that is so
far down the list of reasons trump needs
to be removed that i don't even want to
muddy the water
i i really don't
that indian dude says don't if you are a
fan of geopolitics
but any opinion on the current proxy
conflict between turkey and russia and
central asia and middle east
i i read about that in my personal time
personal time
i am not the person uh who can most
intelligently comment on that
so um you know i would prefer to just
tell you
there's better people uh to give you
takes on that that's not really my uh
my wheelhouse remy lebron says david
what do you say to those on the
progressive left
that want to gatekeep those with your
views from calling themselves
progressive
i mean they can't they can't how can who
okay
they can try but they can't really do
anything
gatekeep who uh i control
my platforms i don't know
um sounds like a waste of time
fidel cash flow says azin is everything
okay
aizen man i don't know vitale says his
trumpet doofus
yeah probably dereten says trump
eligible uk
citizen exit strategy maybe i highly
doubt it
i highly highly doubt that new x guy
says as the trump train d i'm guessing
you mean derails and dismantles
how important is it that we chain these
senators to the engine
and guide it off the cliff if you mean
uh take
control of the senate it is
extraordinarily important
extraordinarily important
uh okay lars says hi devid been
following you for many years can you say
something about why proportional
representation is not more talked about
in the u.s
well i believe it's it's a great idea
it's not more talked about because
it's simply not going to happen anytime
soon unfortunately we need some other
changes to our our electoral system
before we would see that and uh i have
talked about it i
i'm very interested in many aspects of
it
but unfortunately there are steps that
would need to happen before that
oliver wilde says beta male song amazing
thank you composer woodward hope you
have a great weekend david hope you had
a great weekend david
yeah if you're just joining us i did
vote this weekend
uh oh no i lost it hold on
i have video of me voting let me get
that to you
for people who just joined
here's me voting okay in case you missed
it
look at that powerful ballot drop box
and off i go
isn't that a good one
and off i go
so yeah anyway um we all must vote
very very important very very important
uh
okay fox news uh looking looking
a little bit delayed there on fox news
all right very good big thank you to
boss patrol
beta tribus and triton
as well as opacity oh i already thanked
opacity over on twitch
appreciate it thank you other super
chats coming in matthew dominguez says
dodgers versus
rays in the world series who are you
taking david here for the most
most in-depth baseball coverage
available i have not watched a single
game of baseball all season i couldn't
tell you anything
i mean i guess i would go dodgers
because i've been to a game at dodger
stadium i'll go dodgers what the hell do
i know no idea
excuse me uh ant and sharon
david wasn't that the guy that you
debated that knew absolutely nothing
david wasn't that the guy that you
debated that knew absolutely nothing
oh jessie lee peterson you mean yeah i
mean i guess i guess so
that sounds about right college
turnshaw says there's no negative press
so don't you help
trump by rebroadcast his rallies every
day
sure you're a good counter argument man
i don't know what
some of these folks are talking about
but i really appreciate the support
unknown prodigy says oh my god look how
close all these people are this is
literally a super spreader event the
potus is helping to spread the virus
reality just hit me
yeah i mean listen outdoor contagion is
very limited but still
like there was an outdoor rally in
minnesota it seems about 20 cases came
from it so it's not
zero but it's certainly you know
overwhelmingly lower compared to events
that are indoors
um but it's not zero you know 20 cases
still uh it's still something for sure
waffle oh wait uh patrice says david can
you put fauci on your show america needs
it
raised in sharon mass live in san diego
yeah we've invited dr fauci he has not
returned our calls unfortunately but we
would he's welcome
absolutely anytime thanks to nancy
norfleet who is new member
number six today at joinpackman.com
really appreciate that
uh inviting you to grab a membership at
joinpackman.com
um people asking if aoc got back to me
about streaming
uh no i don't think so let me double
check
no she did not and i did i did not
expect her to get back to me
uh okay waffle says
trump leaving the country and agitating
his base is a horror
and samuel sanchez says hey david i
don't agree with most of your views but
i do really enjoy listening to you thank
you
samuel i appreciate that tara says i
think the dem led push for mail-in
voting might be backfiring in michigan
my brother and sister are first-time
voters and voted trump
or prump via mail and ballot i know more
people who have two i am worried
yet you know the numbers uh since we
have time let me pull that up
there i don't know about backfiring per
se
but there are some not so good numbers
out of
michigan let's see where they are right
now
so remember we were expecting the the
mail-in
vote to be overwhelmingly abide in vote
but um republicans have requested more
mail-in ballots in michigan
that's really not good that's really
really not good
because according to polling 75
of mail-in ballots were supposed to be
biden now that's nationally
and in michigan 41 of the mail-in
ballots requested so far
have been republican ballots what does
this mean
only that we can't assume we have any
state any single one of these states
could go to trump
not good okay must vote must must must
vote
no no two ways around it
the coronavirus tracking site was
worldometers.info
all right thank you um
on kit says why do you why do u.s
residents believe government upgrading
basic infrastructure is a waste of money
where else where else is the government
supposed to even spend money except army
uh most americans i think are in favor
of infrastructure spending
but there is certainly a contingent that
is not
ray galaxy says my dad is at the rally
he's going to isolate though
can you like at this point in my life
i whoa i've been to concerts i've been
to sporting events
you know all i've been to political
events i just
wha i would what is going on here i
would just never
even if there was not a pandemic i would
never stand in line
to then be masked together like this
just never i would just never do it
when i've gone to these events i'm
usually in as press
you go in a side door you're right at
the side of the stage and then you leave
and even that i do under protest because
it's like what do i care
but to even to to stand in line
to then stand in the sun in it must be
95 degrees there
on top of it to hear trump speak it's
just
very very ugly stuff very ugly
barbara ryan says trump supporters have
drunk the kook aid yeah well said
jh said there's worry about violence by
trump supporters if he loses
should we worry if he wins because he
will do so only by unfair means and
people probably won't just take it
and justifiably demonstrate let's cross
that bridge when we come to it
okay let's cross that bridge when we
come to it alex says my own pcr reaction
failed for the tenth time in a row to
road today science is hard david
maybe i'll just start an only fans or
something
yeah i don't know alex that's that's a
tough one blazegamer says david what's
your thoughts on boris
johnson infinitely smarter than trump uh
way way way to my right so not somebody
that i would support
kathy black says is that really water
you're always drinking or is it vodka i
don't blame you if it's the latter one
hell of a year
no it's water it's water yep delicious
absolutely delicious water um
college says there's no such thing as
bad publicity aren't you afraid of
rather supporting trump with your videos
i'm sure you have a counter-argument
yeah listen i mean trump debating was a
disaster for his polling
um showing these rallies with no
commentary
probably hurts trump at this point based
on the polling
and showing them with commentary uh
i i think certainly runs no risk
whatsoever of hurting donald of helping
donald trump
carpetbagger says do you think trump
could become a national security threat
if he loses he'd have all sorts of
privileged info in his head would he
trade it
i don't think trump's going to go in
trade info but in terms of what he could
blurt out
absolutely absolutely no no doubt about
it
um big thank you to kendo g g2020
for the subscription over on twitch
uh it is um we we are
trying to get to 100 000 followers on
twitch we were talking internally the
other day
i want to make twitch a huge part of
2021
and um i'm even thinking of doing some
streams
upcoming where after the main event i
don't know if i can do it today if this
starts somewhat soon i might be able to
do it if it doesn't we're out of luck
where at the end of the event we're
watching we will pinch off
all other streams and go exclusive to
twitch and open the phone lines to drive
more traffic to twitch i think that's an
interesting idea
uh people might like that um
but yeah i would love to you know as
many we've been on we've been on youtube
much longer than on twitch and so it's
obviously a much bigger platform we're
getting like a million views a day
on youtube at this point we're over a
million subscribers so on and so forth
um but i think that being more
diversified
uh rather than it's so unbalanced right
now i would like to try to even out
youtube and twitch a little bit and you
know what's absolutely
insane i i'm this is kind of inside
baseball i don't know that anyone even
really cares about this
i was shocked that our
face like you can now publish videos to
facebook facebook has a pretty robust
video publishing
platform at this point our videos on
facebook are starting to rival the size
of our youtube channel
with only a fraction of the fall
i don't even understand what's happening
on facebook maybe it's the pre-election
stuff let me see if i can find
uh exactly what the numbers are i i was
shocked at what's going on let me look
at facebook insights
um in the last seven
days and page activity where is video
views
it was nuts
where is it oh okay yeah so we're often
getting
600 000 views a day on youtube
on facebook rather that's more than half
of what we're getting on youtube it's
like i haven't even been paying
attention to facebook and it has
exploded
um okay anyway we're done people i guess
people
i'm fascinated by this stuff um
but uh let's let's get away from it
people are starting to get a little bit
a little bit angry
okay let's see
um critical canadian says on the plus
side david trump will have a hard time
not wanting those michigan mail-in
ballots counted true
maxim perrapica says michigan wisconsin
data you cited from target early is
predictions not actual registration
counts those aren't released in those
states
i was not those weren't uh those weren't
registration counts those were mail-in
ballot requests
as far as i know shannon bennis says the
overwhelming problem is fox news can you
imagine an antidote to infotainment
they call it infotainment for a reason
it's entertaining to people
which is uh which is sad matthew says
donald trump will announce his victory
the night of the election we shouldn't
have the attitude that we cross the
bridge when we come to it we
know it is coming so let's all act
accordingly
chuch says are you going to play among
us with alexandria ocasio-cortez and
pokeman
no i don't think so i was not invited um
chris r says dropbox and baldwin park
was set on fire comment
i don't know about it i'm against
setting mail drop ballot boxes on fire
um oliver wilde says david what's your
game plan for next election night should
i expect to block out six hours to
follow your live stream that night
yeah my plan on election night is
probably to start streaming at seven
which is when we will get the first
results and then
uh probably you know i'm looking i'm
looking very strongly at seven to
midnight
and here's my idea uh sam cedar's going
to be streaming on election night and
some of our other friends will be
streaming
so my thought is we'll do like an hour
45 so 7 to 8 45
then i'll do a 10 minute break and we'll
cut to like sam cedar's feed for example
and then at 8 55 i'll come back so we
get the 9 pm results
and then i'll just take you know very
short breaks around 45 past
right in advance of the next results
that's my idea
for and that's starting 7 p.m east
7 p.m east on election night that's my
thought
and that's two weeks from tomorrow
that's probably the end of my channel
people keep writing saying david your
channels are circling the drain
and if trump loses it's over for you so
we may be celebrating the end of the
show
on uh november third night let's join
let's all do it together
very exciting day very very exciting day
mike misbach says i voted third party
last election
like you're thinking but often disagree
i was introduced to you on joe rogan
quick sell me on who to vote for if you
think trump is dangerous vote for biden
regardless
of which state you're in period i mean
it's a very simple sale
there's not much to say andrew says
michigan and wisconsin don't keep track
of party affiliation stats so i would
take those numbers with a grain of salt
okay that's important
same site as dems doing way better in
north carolina which does keep track of
party
that is important to know
um champ owns says hawaii turning red
trump 2020
that i don't think that i don't think
edith
puthi says have you ever gotten an
ex-girlfriend's
face and screamed no no
uh alexander hakistad quick question
where do you think historians
will pin the lead up to the trump era
did it start down this path during the
reagan years
or later or even earlier oh man i mean
you could answer that question any
number of ways you could go
you could say that the the start of
anti-intellectual politics
is where the move to trumpism started
but it's like
where did that when did that start we've
seen anti-intellectualism in some form
in the 1800s
we certainly saw people falling for
idiocy under reagan with the welfare
queen with the
you know the cadillac and the ten kids
and all this different stuff you know i
mean
it's all uh it depends on how you draw
the line
and i don't know how it should be drawn
we do have a bunch of people standing
now it seems as though
things things seem to be happening uh
it seems that we may soon be seeing the
arrival
of donald trump we will keep an eye on
it
and see what happens all right we'll see
um thanks to the user give me
your milk please for subscribing for
five months on twitch
with the message alpha pacman always
with the amazing streams
thank you also thanks to mr banjo pants
for subscribing on twitch
um
sean mccracken says youtube only counts
a view if the viewer clicks play
facebook will counter view as being
viewed if it plays for more than three
seconds that is true
that is true semi truck driver says i'm
a bus driver wait hold on a second
your username is truck driver but you're
not actually a truck driver that seems
weird
i'm a bus driver here in florida and i
took 21 joe biden voters to the polls
this morning
nice nice i like that
are you seriously considering leaving
the u.s if trump wins
only briefly only for a few months t
gaines says what's your favorite opening
is white um
i i'm an e4 player and then depending on
what black responds with
i'll play either ponziani or the vienna
game
and i lose with all of them i mean i'm
really bad at chess but
i am soon going to be doing an uh a
lesson with
grand master benjamin feingold we're
we're working on setting it up
and um i'm running a tournament on
chess.com with levy rosman an
up and chess streamer so
and i hope that the tournament we're
going to try to invite some chess
dignitaries
um to play in the tournament so you know
it'll be some
non-political stuff uh which i i'm
actually looking forward to quite a bit
quite a bit lisa says i wish that there
was a waiver for rally-goers to sign to
refuse medical treatment or use
essential services for that matter
nervous in tucson i would be nervous as
well lisa
jules randolph comes in with a 100
i don't know what uh what is that r
what currency is that r 100
have you heard that a u.s appeals court
refused to block the release of
gilene maxwell deposition i did not hear
that yet
um oh i thought trump was taking the
chopper no wonder it's taken longer i
see he took the chopper to a plane i
guess
all right well trump's almost here big
thank you to alex bustamante
who is new member number seven today at
joinpackman.com dina sacks
dmr says hey david donato from the uk
here
isn't trump against state-run health
care then highly praised walter reed is
amazing
which is state run isn't it i believe
isn't walter reed federal
i believe it's federal yes no maybe so
champ owns says hawaii has a very large
movement for trump on all islands every
day are huge rallies for trump
hawaii has never been like this for any
president uh i will bet
whatever anybody wants that trump loses
hawaii
steven robin says d-man it's ray gun if
you pie charted the topics covered in
speeches what do you think the big piece
of the pie would be
i'd have to think about it let's do a
little pie chart right now
uh on my my uh this is i would call this
a legal pad but then attorney stephen
robbins would say this is not legal this
is just a yellow pad i think the
the legal pad is very very long okay
let's do actually hold on i need a
sharpie for this
let's see here there we go all right
so i think that at trump's speeches
about
five percent is what i would just call
verbal glitches
trump saying things like ulysses s grant
minneapolis
that's five percent uh we'll call that
five
i think about a third so this is like
really really big we'll call that
33 percent is just biden
attacks sleepy joe greatest political
crime
you know all that all that different
stuff i would say
probably another i would say
30 is trump with what i would call
false accomplishments
okay so that's 63 68 that leaves us 32.
um ten percent
i think is just introducing people in
the crowd you know saying like
calling matt introducing matt gates but
he calls him rick gates
and stuff like that so that's 15 48 okay
78. so now we've got 22 percent left
this is not to scale what's the other 22
yeah pointless stories meandering
pointless stories where he's like
you know i got home and i told the first
lady
did they cover did they cover my nobel
peace prize
and she said sir no they were talking
about some rainstorm
which was like a hurricane that
devastated you know
a hundred thousand people's lives or
something like that that's that's the
how i would pie chart it basically
um okay and i guess we should include
so somebody said blatant racism that
falls under all of them
thanking people in the crowd attacking
biden and meandering stories
all can contain racism so i would
consider that sort of more of an overlap
big thank you to manuel garth who is new
member number eight today
and penny baker penny baker who is new
member number nine today
love it joinpakman.com we are getting
very close to donald trump's landing in
tucson arizona
um john's cap meyer says keep it up
brandon humble says if trump loses would
he still hold rallies as grieving
rallies as he rambles on for hours as
this is the great political hit job
no i think the trump rallies end very
quickly if trump loses
semi-truck driver says when can we get
an among us stream and baba bowie
if somebody can email me and explain to
me what
among us is and exactly what i would
need to do to play it
or if you can get you know some
prominent streamer to include me in
their among us game
i would look at doing it okay but we've
got 15 days until the election so it's
kind of hard
to do additional i know it's a game guys
i know it's a game
but beyond that i know very very little
about it elboy
says what do you think about rupert
murdoch who owns fox news and his
support of trump
and the fact that trump never mentions
their friendship ever i don't make much
of that that's not something i've given
a lot of thought to
donna williams says please remind people
bernie wants us to vote
biden yeah listen guys i'm with bernie
and i'm with chomsky
i'm voting biden i'm with bernie and i'm
with chomsky
i in fact i already voted biden if you
are just joining us here is video of me
voting
extremely powerfully over the weekend
i had full insertion into the drop box i
made sure that none of my ballot
was left sticking out so nobody could
you know remove it or anything like that
pop right in there and then double
thumbs up and then just drift off
the screen so there it is i voted folks
i voted
very windy as you can tell extremely
windy day it was here
uh here in new england so there it is
igor bellayev says what do you think
of accuracy of prediction on accuracy
on election results what do you think of
accuracy of
oh predicted.org on accuracy
i don't know i don't know enough to say
i figured it should be more accurate
since people use money to express their
opinions yeah that
i don't know how accurate predict it was
last year
last election rather
um what did i miss trump embodies my
name and i love producer lewis
oh oh oh oh i was just texting with
producer lewis this may come as a
as a stunning revelation producer lewis
just had the virus some people call it
corvid 19.
we call it coronavirus lewis had the
virus he just told me
um he said he had very little symptoms
but he just lost his sense of smell and
taste
so then he got the test and um
[Music]
uh what else just some congestion
popped up after but producer lewis has
had
the virus as we know it um and we may be
actually lewis is participating in a big
gaming charity stream over the next
short period of time and i may i may
participate
so keep an eye out producer lewis may be
making a return
very very soon very very soon thanks to
anna silverio
wait hold on anna siverio who is new
member number 10 today
at joinpakman.com donald trump's
landing in tucson arizona in mere
minutes
in mere minutes uh as i mentioned i may
or may not be covering the full
rally we're gonna get a sense of trump's
mood today
increasingly i'm not feeling the need to
cover the entire rally but we'll just
play it kind of as it as it comes
kevin says would i ever invite brian
tyler cohen onto the program
it's not that i wouldn't it's just that
i tend not to have
people on the show who do the same thing
i do like other hosts of channels
the audience is is not typically that
interested in it
so i tend not to do it but uh you know i
would do
some kind of a um of a collab with him
sure
sure jeb says hi david do you think that
cambridge analytica style ads might have
an impact this election keep up the good
work
uh i i mean impact in what sense you
would have to tell me
psychology says do you have any personal
friends who support trump
not really not really no not at this
point
i had friends who voted bush for example
or mccain you know
a little punch drunk says oh nothing
they retracted their message
trigvy smedsrud says norway is rooting
for biden trump is bat crap crazy
decency 2020 ps love your show thank you
i appreciate that the dude says do you
think them numbers saying more
registered republicans could be people
who identify as republican
but still registered to vote against
trump at this point anything is possible
anything is possible at this point in
time yeah uh it could be
any all of the above uh
let's see
um sweet baby bladefoot says jamie from
majority report says you're not a
leftist because of your bad politics
about u.s
imperialism thoughts on bolivian
election um
have not looked at bolivian election
very focused on this election
um i don't know even that jamie said
that but i'm against u.s
intervention in basically every
situation globally and have been
for decades so if someone wants to tell
me what about that position
is not left um i would i would love to
hear it
but certainly i have no idea i don't
know that i've ever seen
jamie say anything so i don't
have any idea if that's even the type of
thing she would say that may be
completely untrue
if that's untrue i'm sorry jamie
i don't know that you said anything at
all i don't even know if jaime knows who
i am quite frankly i've had no
interaction in my life
with jamie um but
if anybody wants to send me the clip
they are referring to
um i would be glad to see it by the way
why would jamie from majority report
even be talking about me like who what
i've i've
it's who cares what i it's just weird if
that it's almost
it would almost be weirder if it were
true
let me put it that way okay emily saint
sir
says do trump supporters brains have
quantum properties
only way to explain how their beliefs
include so many contradictory realities
exist at once
maybe that's it maybe that's it um
let's see oh someone goaded sam
cedar on a lark send me that that's
interesting let's look at that video if
some if
anybody knows about exactly where i can
find that
send me a um
if you email me that i want to hear the
exact time
code and video then i would review that
because that sounds absolutely
i love when sam gets goaded into talking
about me which i don't think is
something he's ever interested in doing
i'll keep an eye out in my email for
that we could very strongly review that
okay jorge diaz jorge diaz is new member
number eleven
graeme fern is new member number twelve
scott
watt wiedrich is new member number
thirteen kurt
scowen is new member number 14
uh at joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that today thank you very
much
um okay
um scrawly tv says
dipping now that trump's almost here
just want to hear your voice while i
cook dinner thanks for the soothing
sounds my pleasure glad to be here
stranger danger says his producer louis
doing among us
just pulling your leg david thanks for a
good job with everything the dp show
are doing thank you i appreciate that
owen downey says i'm guessing these
propaganda rallies are spreading corona
but is there any hard data available yet
uh minimally there are some cases yes
certainly some cases
uh coming from here from these rallies
candace says already voted early in
person hopefully flipping north carolina
to blue
i'm a mail carrier and sick of political
mail yes absolutely
it does look as though donald trump
people are asked trump has landed people
asking me to play the sam cedar video
i need someone to email it to me through
my website with the time code
that's the only way that i can do it i i
don't i don't have it in front of me
it's hard to uh
it's hard to find it uh let me mention
i would absolutely love it
if you grabbed a membership on my
website joinpakman.com we are primarily
funded by website memberships one of the
most exciting
member benefits is that every day we do
an
extra show only available to members
but most importantly it feels good to
support things you like
and believe in now if you don't like me
and you don't believe we should exist
don't get a membership at joinpakman.com
that's the last thing you should do
if you're down to your last dollar or
two don't get a membership at
joinpakman.com but i would love it if
you did
consider yourself humbly invited we have
a very modest target of 25 new members
today
we are only 11 away and secret
although it's up on the screen coupon
code 2020 now
saves you 66 okay
use the coupon code don't use the coupon
code your call
but that coupon code is an extremely
extremely powerful coupon code
um and it will i would love to see this
bar fill up why that's just me
that's just me as we await donald
trump's arrival here
people continuing me to ask continuing
to ask me to play the sam cedar clip
again i can't play the clip unless
somebody sends me a link
and a time code through my website
a lot of people seem to want to see it
but i i don't have the video
i need somebody to email me the video
okay other super chats coming in let's
see what else we've got
um thought on roe v wade being
overturned and sending the moral ethical
choice to states to decide portions of
women's healthcare well of course i
believe roe v wade should stay
but i actually think that to some degree
roe v wade is better
as uh an enemy it's better as an enemy
for the right uh rather than actually
getting rid of it
okay somebody sent me the sam cedar clip
let's see here
you can vote for someone else who your
favorite is oh
oh my god now we've got an ad hold on
let me see here
everything going wrong
kyle and i uh uh kyle's
beating me by almost two percentage
points people gotta get
on that i barely know who these other
people are
who kyle or david pakman or joe
i mean i know about pacman because you
guys talk about him constantly
and you know jimmy dore as well but you
don't talk about kyle kalinski that much
so
only vaguely aware also i don't know how
pac-man gets to call himself
leftist when he's got such bad politics
around imperialism
wonder what he has to say about the
election in bolivia no kidding right
no kidding medicare for more please
any news has she ever even seen my show
that is that's very very funny
uh i i only know her as you know sam's
uh
i don't know what she does there i i i
guess is she a co-host or something like
that
but uh oh she's a communist oh i had no
idea
i did i had no idea about that is that
true she's actually a communist
okay maybe people are joking i have no
idea i don't i don't know anything about
her
uh but that's funny yeah i mean it's
like
how many times can i say i'm against
american meddling
in essentially every situation
unless you find me one maybe i agree
with i don't know how many ways i can
say it
and then the problem is my view on
imperialism it's bizarre
that is crazy uh
she is a communist okay all right uh sam
mad at a caller over david pakman let's
see what that is that sounds interesting
oh um i've actually to be honest
i've been watching david pakman a lot
more and it's really unfortunate i don't
really care for him
um he's just he just goes live more um
he covers a lot of uh
he covers a lot of you know live
political things like the
amy coney berry bear hearings and
everything yeah
yeah oh um that's right i don't even get
that i don't even
i don't even understand what that's
about uh
okay i don't know man this is like
this you know it's actually sad because
and again
i i have no idea what jamie's politics
are people are saying that she's a
communist i
i have no idea if that's true um
what is wrong on the left when people
start doing this stuff you know it's
like i don't even
i don't even get involved in any of this
stuff it's like she doesn't like me
okay but you know starting to do this
stuff where oh this person's not really
on the left that person's not really on
the left
it seems uh it seems
terrible it seems genuinely terrible
um okay other people signing up martin
eckendall is new member number 15.
mike bugbee has signed up on patreon and
is number
16 today sandra goins
is number 17 silas dunigan
is number 18 at joinpackman.com
very very much appreciate that uh really
really appreciate the
the support that has been coming in
let's see
other super chats um
let's see what else we've got here
um oh wait people are sending me more
clips now of stuff they want me to play
other people oh yeah i don't even know
now people are sending me clips that are
from other shows that are bashing me
yeah i'm not even gonna get involved in
that i mean listen this is the most
toxic thing i think that there's
shows that are just um desperate for me
to talk about them
like to give them attention that guys
there's no time for that there's no time
for that we we really can't do that
um okay and by the way i'm not even
going to give her
give give them i don't know i guess this
is a guy someone sent me somebody named
central committee it's like what does
that even mean i don't even know what
that means
they want me to talk i guess central
committee bashed me i have no clue who
that is
i have no interest in giving him or her
the time of day so don't even bother
or them don't even bother sending me
that stuff
dustin says what is your honest take on
how necessary and how realistic it is to
hold the trump administration
accountable when they are out of office
if by listen trump's not going to jail
trump's not going to prison
so um you know it depends on what you
mean by accountability
hopefully there will be accountability
in terms of his
um business dealings hopefully there
will be some people
if there are indeed crimes that have
been committed notice how i'm not
calling for the suspension of due
process
if there are crimes that have been
committed hopefully there will be people
around trump that are held accountable
but anybody waiting for the trump in
handcuffs moment i mean you know it's
i i wouldn't hold my breath for that
charlie says david when you achieve
global domination and take your
enterprise public
what will your ticker symbol be i have
no interest in going public
no interest eric says what's the typical
waiting time to vote in person in the
u.s here it's just in and out
listen where i have lived in the four or
five places i've lived i never wait the
the biggest weight i've had is five
minutes but that is exactly the problem
in the us that it's extraordinarily
stratified extraordinarily stratified
and um you know that that's
arguably by design uh i live in i've
always voted in states that are very
blue
so there's very little to gain by making
it tough to vote it's like
does the does the democrat win by an
insane amount or a lot
it's very different in other areas
where there is much more to gain by
suppressing the vote
in certain parts of the country that's
the reality
edgar says oh
lived in your homeland for three and a
half years and returned to this okay um
so edgar pointing saying he lived in my
homeland for oh well that parts in
english
[ __ ] like trump the whole world is
laughing at us okay yeah i mean
yes yes completely agree
joey says a trump supporter told me if
trump should release his tax return so
should biden scary this is why we must
vote right biden did
that's what's you know sounds like
idiocy
sounds like significant significant
idiocy
uh scott herzer is new member number 19
today at joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that
this is like the day the day to sign up
at joinpakman.com before we run out of
memberships which would be horrible
john henson says when is the mainstream
stream media going to ask trump
where all the arrests are for voter
fraud he's in charge of the fbi cia nsa
so either he sucks or there is no fraud
he would just say that they're against
him and that the intelligence
community's against him and everybody's
against him and he's just a big big
victim
that's what he would say pablo says what
do you think world leaders will do if
trump declares false victory greetings
from germany
listen if it's clearly false i don't see
world leaders accepting it
period um if trump
actually wins okay well you know
then i assume they will say trump won i
mean what what else
what else can they do but if it's if
it's really false
i expect world leaders will just stay
silent until uh we have more information
big thank yous over on twitch dally
madison has subscribed for five months
with prime says i wonder if trump paid
his bill to the city of tucson yet
they should issue tickets at the rally
for violations of the mandatory mask
policy might help with the deficit well
said
shaded elmo has subscribed with prime
ramirez blackrock has subscribed with
prime
and amy yesuda has also subscribed with
prime
appreciate it d-money says do you ever
dabble into streaming games could be fun
only chess when we run tournaments and
like once i did a
super mario world speed run
as a complete and total joke but i'm i'm
pretty busy with the politics to do too
much game streaming to be perfectly
honest
uh let's see
what other super chats here
what does all of this mean nothing vote
jethro says what's one thing you would
ask trump if he agreed to a short
interview with
you uh do you do you know when you're
telling lies and do you tell them
because you think your followers are
stupid
i just saw a man defecating in front of
children okay
liam says sam cedar firing yet another
shot across the bow remembering the
great
bot scandal of summer 2020 wow
wow i voted yes on ranked choice in
massachusetts
danny asking about that
jojen says you didn't support bernie the
most progressive yes i did
this is just boring stuff guys danny
says hilarious on the clip
from sam cedar's show you live rent free
in sam's head for sure
in sam or or the woman who co-hosts with
him i don't know but yeah there seemed
to be
uh there seemed to be vitriol there that
was weird
big thank you to jacob luttrell
who is new member number 20
reuben martens is new member number 21
and jose via is new member number 22 or
visha as we would say in argentina
um thomas is furious says david enough
with sam cedar and destiny every time
you entertain these morons it validates
them that's ugly guys that's
that's that's an ugly attack we don't
need that jennifer higgins says i have
literally had to take a break from most
progressive news channels because of how
heated they get
you are the only exception because you
keep us informed without the emotional
tone and for that i thank you well i
thank you for the support
here comes donald trump uh working his
way down let's see what music is playing
[Music]
okay it's very very weird there thank
you to post happy streams for
gifting some subs over on twitch
insatiablehunger says can you make a top
five facts
why you should vote for biden mostly for
us gen z
who can't even concentrate to a 20
minute video
something like epoch times um yeah i'll
look into that
that's interesting
juice says have you seen the new zealand
election results yes
very powerful jonathan velazquez
says saludos
greetings right back to you danny says
did you vote for rank choice voting i
voted yes
i voted yes
um
tato says genocidal governments should
be overthrown by its people
all right a little bit of grammatical
ambiguity there
stephen says david who's your favorite
president or top five i just don't think
about politics in that way
so i don't have i don't have such a list
brian colby says i figured you'd come
out in gold chains and show off those
gold teeth today love it make sure
i get out and vote and sign up for a
membership absolutely
absolutely in fact um i want to say
thanks to
glenn peshky who grabbed a membership at
joinedpakman.com
number 23 we are dangerously close to
reaching our goal of 25 new members
dan it's getting dangerous very very
dangerous
oliver wilde says biden should stack the
supreme court
if only to restructure i'd love to
discuss via discord one of these days
all right well maybe you will get the
opportunity someday
uh let's see
green party trevor says comments on
bolivia election love you david
i i i have no idea i've not even seen
the results
uh but i think bolivia should hold
elections i am very much in favor of
them doing that and for the winner
to become the president and the u.s
should not intervene how's that for
imperialism the u.s should have no role
in bolivian elections
thanks to kate pepin who is new member
number 24
today at joinpakman.com
el dude says kolinsky speaks highly of
you
that's interesting would love to see
clips of that
can review them together with you as we
get ready to hear from trump here
uh let's see if there's still music
playing
[Music]
oh my god it's pathetic spruce says are
you concerned about the lincoln project
if biden wins
yeah they're just republicans i mean you
know they'll go back to being
republicans or you know
they'll still be republicans essentially
a big thank you to samantha ramanan
who is new member number 25 you know
what happens when we get to 25.
i say let's go for 50. let's do it i
believe we can as we get ready to hear
from donald trump uh
very warm very very warm right now in
tucson
let's see what donald trump has to say
oh my god it's still going we're gonna
hear from him very soon very soon oliver
[ __ ] is new member number 26
at joinpackman.com thanks oliver
james montalbano says i long for a world
when the phrase
trump rally didn't exist you and me both
hayden says delete facebook leading
source of miss info
azidji says how long do you think it
will take for us to see a major
electoral reform in the u.s
at least four years at least four years
the song is still going trump's just
waiting brian says thoughts on the
new zealand labor party will govern
alone or if jacinda ardern may invite
the greens and mayori party into
government
you got to find someone who's more
steeped in new zealand politics
thank you doosan thank you tousan
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
well thank you very much tucson i'm
thrilled to be in arizona with the
thousands of loyal
hard-working american patriots
15 days from now we're going to win the
state of arizona
and we are going to win four more
years in that beautiful white house
everybody needs to get out and vote
return your absentee ballot
or vert you know you can go out there i
think today you got to avert
today go vert right now you can go and
vote today
they say today go out and vote that
beats a ballot do you agree that beats a
ballot
remember the old-fashioned days when
you'd actually go out and vote today
they send you millions of ballots
are you okay over there everyone fine
good okay
he looks better than i do that yeah i'm
better than i do
good thank you you make sure you're okay
with your vote we'll continue to cut
your taxes and regulations
maintain energy independence which we
have
strengthen our military support our
police protect our
second amendment
i don't know i don't see you people i
don't think you're going to want to give
up those guns i don't think so
that's not that's not for arizona
defend our borders arrest violent
criminals and confirm more
judges to uphold the rule of law
nightmare under my leadership
prosperity will surge what we've done in
the last
three and a half years has been
incredible nobody's ever done
what we've done there is no
administration that's accomplished
what we've accomplished in the first
three and a half years
not even close
optimism will boom the pandemic it's
rounding the turn
we're about to hit new records and i
look fine don't i you know
and we'll get back to a normal life
that's what we want just the normal just
seven months ago we want to get back
and we'll be better than that very soon
we built the foundation that's so strong
and you see what's happening stock
market through the roof
euphoria isn't it down 400 today your
stocks
through the roof you're housing through
the roof everything is good
your optimism and what about 56
of the people just a gallup poll just
came out
56 of the people say they're better off
today
than they were four years ago and we
have a pandemic
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country that's what's going to happen
we're cutting your taxes they're raising
your taxes that's uh
an easy one to figure out isn't it this
election is a choice between
a trump super recovery or a biden
depression
[Laughter]
that's a lie it's a choice between
getting a safe vaccine and getting back
in and working
and by the way you have a governor here
today he's done a great job and he's
kept you open
you're open unlike some of them like
michigan
you know we won the case in michigan you
know the only one that was allowed to
have a good time was the governor's
husband
he was allowed to do whatever the hell
he wanted but nobody else they were like
in a prison
but we're gonna have a safe vaccine and
uh biden you know what he's gonna do
lock him down let's lock everybody down
nah but we built the greatest economy
ever we had to close it down
we saved millions of lives by doing what
we did then we built it back up
and now we're doing record type numbers
and it's a choice between the american
dream or a socialist nightmare that's
what it is
biden will delay therapies postpone the
vaccine prolong the pandemic
close your schools and shut down our
country
and we're opening and we're opening
rapidly and we've got a v
shape it may be a super v it looks like
it's a super v which nobody ever even
heard of before
he will massively raise your taxes bury
your
you will be buried in regulations you
know we cut regulations
it would take 18 to 21 years to get a
highway approved
we have it down to one year and you know
what
from two to one we're very shortly to be
exact right now it's less than
two we're gonna have it down to one year
and it may get rejected for
environmental reasons or safety and
that's okay
probably not but that's okay but you
know what you're gonna have it
approved or not approved and it's a
one-year process not a 21-year process
and this has gone on all over the
country and in my opinion
what we've done on regulations is even
more important
than the biggest tax cut in the history
of our country i think it's more
important
and you've done what now those
regulations
they want to dismantle your police
departments
dissolve your borders dissolve your
borders if you don't have borders you
don't have a country
confiscate your guns ban american energy
wipe out literally none of that is true
there is not
one accurate thing there religious
liberty
this is for the women the women who live
in the suburbs they want to destroy
your suburbs and i ended the rule that
was going to destroy
i ended the regulation that was going to
decide i kept hearing that women from
the suburbs won't like trump i said why
because i'm stopping crime
you're gonna have suburbs be safe
suburbs you're having safe
suburbs and you're not gonna have low
income housing projects built next to
your house
we ended the regulation that would have
destroyed your suburbs
it's amazing how the women like me all
of a sudden
and as you know the democrats they want
to cut
our military to the bone and we built
the greatest military right now in the
history
of our country frankly in the history of
the world
biden will surrender your jobs to china
he will surrender your future to the
virus
and he will surrender your country to
the radical
socialist left and you see that
happening
the only thing for that to be possible
there has to be a radical socialist left
in power to surrender to and of course
there isn't
i didn't know anything about it oh
here's a picture of biden playing golf
with these people
i didn't know my son was taking money
from
barista i didn't know my son got three
and a half billion dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife i wonder why
and then you see all the things right
that
we have to give the man 10 we have to
give the man
10 right oh boy
i'll tell you what nobody's ever seen
and the media right and big tech
they won't they won't allow it it's
everybody's fault but
you know charlie kirk oh no is he gonna
talk about charlie
shut down his site because he mentioned
it his sight
he's a corrupt politician this guy he's
a corrupt politician
kirk to get the power biden has made a
corrupt bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination
he has handed control of his party over
to the socialists the communist the
marxist and the left-wing
extremists and that's before we get to
his own personal corruption
which is more than anybody in history
i say this it's the second biggest
scandal politically
in the history of our country number one
was spying on my campaign
[Laughter]
martin even chose as his running mate
the most liberal senator in america
kamala kamala
kamala harris is a sponsor of the
socialist green new deal
and legislation to strip away the
private health plans
of 180 million americans and you know
her and bernie sanders want to do
something in arizona they have some deal
in arizona where
your taxes are going to go way up you
know that right lie
your governor who's right over here your
great governor was saying he's not happy
with it
but bernie sanders the second most
liberal person you know she's first
right she's considered
they want to raise your taxes eight and
a half percent wrong i'm glad
right governor he's saying more
it's probably more
what's funny is if it's more than eight
and a half percent trump's not telling
you the truth like
trump's not right because he's
understating it trump's giving you the
wrong number
even if it were higher which of course
it's not this is crazy gunzo
harris also urged their supporters to
donate to a fund
that bailed out the riot as the ones
that knocked out your towns your cities
not in republican areas by the way all
in democrat areas
you look at portland how about that we
would have taken 15 minutes we could
have solved that
we told the governor democrat let us in
we'll solve that problem
we went into minneapolis it took us a
half an hour that was over with
unfortunately they could have called a
little earlier and in seattle they gave
up when they heard we were going in the
next morning
but we would tell look all democrat
areas new york going to hell i feel so
sad with new york
200 250 he's out of his mind
a terrible thing has happened in new
york look at chicago
democrat again crime is through the roof
they had a weekend 87 people were shot
and 16 died okay now do you believe this
isn't
hey we're in afghanistan you don't lose
many people we're coming out by the way
it's all coming
we're all coming back home everybody's
coming
you go to war zones you don't have that
they're all home and we could solve it
so easily
thank you thank you
thank you you know there's never been
that chance before seriously
we all like ronald reagan i guess he'd
be but
he never had that share we love you
thank you dad we love you
what a sycophant huh you're gonna make
me cry don't do that i don't want to
grow
cringe it's total cringe
make me cry you'll destroy my image and
then you won't love me anymore that'll
be terrible
i appreciate it that's really trump's
main concern that's why i'm doing this i
had a good life before i did this stuff
believe me my life was very simple and
very nice yeah
the democrat party's warrior cops is
inciting riots and putting police
officers in american family
of visitors unlike joe biden i will
always support the heroes of law
enforcement
and i was endorsed by almost every
law enforcement group in the united
states
including new york's finest in chicago
and
florida and texas and oklahoma and every
place
and i was just named i have to say this
happened today the man of the year in
their big magazine the blue magazine
good name for
man of the year so i just tell you that
for whatever reason i tell you
i'm the only one standing between you
and a
left-wing crusade you know change our
whole country
for the better and the thing that's
going to bring us back together a
success
because i'll tell you we were ready i
was getting calls
seven months ago we had the best
employment numbers we
ever had with the greatest success we've
ever had
we were beating china at everything you
know you kept hearing about
we were beating everybody and they were
calling me people that i wouldn't be
speaking to generally
let's get together it was happening and
then we got hit by the china plague
and then we had to start all over again
all over well success
brings us together what a victim we saw
it for two months it was really going on
a new study of the biden harris agenda
found that their
plans will crater the typical american
family
by more than six thousand five hundred
dollars they're horrible horrible
absolutely ridiculous the new the new
green deal
anybody who hears that should
immediately say how could it six
thousand that makes no sense
no more airplanes no more double cars
no more cows if you have a ranch double
cars
no more you you'll be next in just three
years i
increased family income by six thousand
dollars
and we're not even talking about the
energy did you ever think you'd be
seeing two dollar gasoline again and you
got that
and it's plentiful nowhere to go all our
energy jobs
all of our energy jobs we saved biden
will eviscerate the middle class my
policies will lift
the middle class to record highs and
that's where we're going very quickly
remember biden's tax plan lower taxes
lowers taxes for the bottom 95 chipped
away your jobs
shut down your factories threw open your
borders
and ravaged our cities while sacrificing
american blood and treasure in these
endless ridiculous
foreign wars in countries you've never
even heard of
joe biden is what trump means is
countries he's never heard of the
lobbyists the wealthy donors the
washington vultures
who got rich bleeding america dry you
know they raise a lot of money the
democrats you know why because they make
deals
they make deals i would be the greatest
fundraiser in history if i wanted to
call wall street i know them all
i want 10 million dollars for my
campaign yes sir all i have to say is i
want 10 million i want 15 i want 25.
i would set every record but you know
what happens when you do that you're
selling yourself out
when you have to do something you can't
do it anymore
you feel guilty strange explanations
setting all sorts of records i know what
the records are the records every time
they set a record they gave away
everything
in 2016 you voted to fire this corrupted
decrepit political
establishment and you elected an
outsider as president
who is finally putting america first
it's about time joe biden as always and
always has been a corrupt
politician joe biden is a corrupt
politician
and you know what you knew that and a
lot of people knew it for a long
time trump's not corrupt it's over
it's over
and as far as i'm concerned the biden
family is a
criminal enterprise and that's what it
is criminal enterprise
smoking gun emails shown we just found
them you saw that
did you see a shifty shift we think that
the uh
laptop was made by russia oh i see
oh oh he just said it was made
remember guys rudy giuliani admitted
it's a 50 50 chance he worked with a
russian spy on the story
fox news refused to run with the story
because
it wasn't properly sourced understand
these are sick people
do you notice they never say it was made
by china
because they're all on the take.
smoking gun email show just came out
that the biden
family used the vice presidency as a
for-profit cash machine
and that joe biden has been lying to the
american public to cover it up
remember he said no i never met anybody
from barista is it is it barista
actually that i understand because he's
got no memory left it's gone
is it barista no i don't really and then
they show a picture of him playing golf
with the head of barista
oh boy oh boy if biden wins
china wins and china will own
the usa remember what i said
this is so stupid big tech is trying to
hide the entire scandal do you believe
what they're doing
they're taking people like a charlie
kirk and others off
if they even mention that biden is
corrupt
and they know he's corrupt but he's
there corrupt he's so perfect for them
he's there corrupt because they know
that publicizing these
gonna just look at some new polls while
trump talks of biden's
presidential run i think it's an end
right now look
you know i think it's an end right now
how the hell can you do when you see the
kind of things that they do
where the big guy has to get at least 10
the big guy i wonder who the big guy is
t i wonder
when you see what if you put him as
president you should be ashamed of
yourselves you want to know the truth
i'm not just running
against biden i'm running against the
left-wing media
the big tech giants and the washington
swamp and i've been running against it
from the beginning
speaking of arizona
and here i am all by myself it's truly
oh yeah yeah anybody else that would
have been in a corner right now
thumb in mouth saying mommy take me home
mommy i want to go home
now it's uh it's great you know why it's
great though because nobody's ever done
what we've done
nobody wow
[Applause]
wait are they in are they on on
ironically saying drain the swamp
about trump
they flood your communities with
criminal aliens
drugs and crime while they live behind
beautiful
gated communities like trump try to take
away your guns
while they enjoy private security fully
armed
like trump how fully armed how about
bloomberg we are fighting guns and he's
got five guys around him with guns
they support crippling lockdowns while
their jobs and their industry remain
totally exempt it's time to send a
message to these wealthy liberal
hypocrites
in washington and in silicon valley it's
too much
the american people are in charge by
delivering
their chosen candidate sleepy joe biden
who shouldn't even be there candidate
he should have lost because elizabeth
pocahontas warren
if she would have dropped out the day
before super tuesday
casual xenophobia lost every single
state
to crazy bernie it's a very simple
business but we have to show them
the democrats a thundering defeat on
november 3rd
wow and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder
than anyone has ever fought for you
which is true and i'm fighting so hard i
had a great life
i'm fighting so hard because i love
my country and because i'm determined to
ensure
that the forgotten men and women of this
country
are never forgotten again and they won't
be
they won't be who's he talking about and
we talked that lesson to him four years
ago
oh my god my discord just exploded
because this is the most
important you know i used to go a few
months ago say well i don't know this is
important that's important which is more
important this is the most important
election in the history of our country
divided agenda would be a catastrophe
for
arizona seniors do we have any seniors
in the house
biden is pledging mass amnesty and free
masks
rapidly coming off behind trump we've
now got one
two three four off five off
give free health care it's almost
everybody
actually immigrants right they said to
illegal immigrants
right and everybody raised their hand
and biden couldn't get us up
because he knew you know he's been doing
this crap for 47 years right
he's gone he couldn't he knew it was
wrong but then he looked and his brain
is shot so he looked over there
and their hands were all up then he
looked over there and their hands were
all up
there were a lot of them he knew it was
wrong because it would be
so horrible for our country because
everyone's going to flood our country
you get free health care
right you get free health care you get
free education
i jokingly said and everybody gets a
rolls royce
and cnn said that's a lie so what
happened
he didn't get it up and then he looked
and he looked and he got it up and i
said thank you we just won the election
what is he talking about i don't care if
he did that
and it's not going to be up to him
that's his party that's what they want
they want socialized medicine
and he'll destroy your social security
while i'm president
no one will touch your medicare or your
social security
like under biden right you know the
amazing thing biden's always complaining
oh he didn't stop china fast enough
except he didn't want to stop him at all
you know little things like this
but you know he's always complaining and
yet he was here for 47 years
right i said joe joe do you guys think
that that 47 years talking point works
like do people hear that and say yeah
that's bad
biden's bad biden had 47 years to fight
for seniors and reducing oh you think it
does oh interesting a bunch of people
say it does work i've just exercised
they're going to come down 70 80 90
percent
because i just did something that nobody
thought anybody would do
a favorite nation's flaws we pay the
lowest in the world
you'll see numbers that are shocking
they're not happy with me the big pharma
big pharma is spending a lot of money
when you see those ads please remember
every one of those ads means your drug
prices are coming down
they can't believe it i could deal with
them i did i tried
there's a lack of cause and effect to a
lot of what trump mentions i don't know
if you guys noticed that
but you know last year we brought drug
prices down one percent i'm not bragging
about
it's the first time in 52 years that
drug prices came down
but now we're going for the big one now
we're going for the big one
and you know rebates you know the
richest people the middlemen you know
the middlemen about drugs you know that
we have middlemen nobody knows who the
hell they are never hear middle women i
hear middlemen so
we'll make it politically correct
middlemen middle no they're called
middlemen
nobody knows who they are
who are they for a businessman he
understands very little about different
businesses
hunter biden is a middleman on top of
everything else
he gets it from china he gets it from
ukraine
he got three and a half million from
russia from moscow
he got three and a half and on top of
everything else he's a middle man
i'll bet he is he probably gets a piece
of the action but instead he sold
seniors out
to the drug lobby and the big farmer
that's biden senior
farmer i'm taking on the powerful
special interest like never before
nobody's ever done this before
nobody's ever done it before i mean you
know for years you heard about drug
prices nobody ever did anything
and now you hear about drug prices and
they're dropping they're going to be
dropping like a rock
also i'm letting your governor your
great governor
buy until the thing kicks in and
probably litigation
but you know i've exercised this whole
thing with favored nations so
if germany pays 10 cents for a pill and
we're paying two and a half dollars and
you have that kind of disparities
ridiculous
that we have the right to match in other
words we get the lowest price but until
it kicks in
canada pays half of what we pay so i'm
letting your governor and other
governors go to canada buy your drugs
through canada
save 50 percent we get rid of the
middlemen
the irony of a trump crowd cheering
about buying drugs in another country
is is hilarious actually they don't even
have the capacity to understand the
hilarity of it
for medicare plans at less than 35
a month people were dying because they
couldn't afford insulin
33 million seniors 30 seniors
35 but 33 million seniors
on medicare will soon be receiving
200 to help with their drug course on
top of everything else
nobody's done by the way in all fairness
nobody has done anything like this
but your big thing your big thing is
going to be when you see what happens
with the favorite nations because you've
been hearing about it for years
where other countries are paying a tiny
fraction this is like
painfully stupid because because our
politicians sold us out
they sold us out but i'm not a
politician so it's one of the i couldn't
stand watching it
to battle the china virus we launched
the largest
mobilization since world war ii our
early and aggressive action
saved more than two million lives i
acted early to ban
travel from china and ch tr how about
this
you should have done it but in the
meantime when i did it he called me
xenophobic
right and then months later he agreed
that i was right and now he's saying i
should have done it sooner
this guy i also banned it from
europe because i saw with italy and with
spain and with france and
by the way they have a big spike right
now they have a very big spike right now
and we're doing good
nothing compared to our case numbers
vaccine's coming and all but even
without
we're rounding the turn man he has no
idea or he's a liar
or both probably pandemic out you know
that they're pandemiced out
that's why it's so great what your
governor's done he's opened up your
state you're doing great
we pioneered life's and by the way you
get it
you know like i say here i am i'm here
i'm here and now i'm immune i can jump
into this audience and kiss
every man and woman i'm immune
right up until trump did that but he was
losing the crowd they were bored you're
immune for life and then when i got it i
said i'm immune they said it's only good
for four months see if anybody else
you understand that right i'll jump into
that audience right there
we pioneered life-saving therapies and
reduced the fatality rate
85 think of it he keeps lying about that
i didn't feel good i feel not so great
and i'm not used to that
and we can't let that happen to a
president because we not we have to be
at the top of our game that's why you
all biden be president because he's not
at the top of his game mentally can't
have that
one thing i can tell you putin president
xi of china
kim jong-un all of them macron they're
very much at the top of their game you
can't let this happen to our country
you can't but i was i was laying and you
know if you're president
one thing you're guaranteed lots of
doctors and they would grab me
they grabbed me by every part they had
hands all over me i said get the hell
out of here i just don't feel good
and we ended up i used the drug
regeneron which nobody ever
remember that's the name of the company
not the drug and i woke up the next
morning and i was like i felt like
superman
get me out of here i said get me out of
here
and eli lilly makes a similar product
product i'm gonna distribute that we're
trying to get emergency use so we can do
it faster
because it's early but it's fantastic
antibodies
and we're gonna distribute it all over
and we're going to make sure that people
that have a problem they get the same
problem and i'm telling you it'll be the
same result
it'll be the same result and it's free
really exciting new products for
coronavirus
customers because it's not their fault
it's china's fault it's not their fault
but i woke up and i felt good i said get
me out of here boom superman
through operation warp speed we will
have 100 million vaccine doses before
the end of the year
and our military is going to distribute
them and they are there's nobody like
remember two weeks ago it was before the
election we would have approval we would
have early doses before the election
the vaccine will end the pandemic but
even without the vaccine
the pandemic is ending it's gonna end it
ends with it but you know this can
this can go quickly this can make it go
a lot faster biden's locked down
we'll crush america my plan will crush
the virus and bring back your american
dream
so we're joined today by some very
special people
a friend of mine somebody that's been
with here we go time for the
introduction
he's very difficult because when he
needs something for the state like money
remember 100 million doses is only
enough for 50 million people if it's a
two dose vaccine which it looks like it
will be supposed to do right
that's what you want he's supposed to
call and finally i'll say all right doug
you got it get out of here promise not
to call then he'll call me two weeks
later i need more
but he's a great governor one of the
greatest governors he's done a fantastic
job you're down to very low numbers by
the way
doug ducey doug please
[Music]
oh he's bringing him up oh no
we want you to vote for martha mcsally
your second amendment she is going down
so hard guys
she'll never be able to show her face
again doug you want to come up
come here for a second
a lot of booze actually for doug ducey
yeah i'll tell you this guy has been a
great gun i don't know if you like him
tonight i don't care he's been a great
governor yeah trump hears the booze as
well
donald trump will win arizona
donald trump will be re-elected
president of the united states
and along with donald trump and mike
pence
martha mcsally and nick will join them
in the u.s
senate
mr president because of your policies
arizona's economy is booming
our home values are rising faster
than anywhere else in the nation and amy
coney barrett will be confirmed to the
supreme court
what does that have to do with the
governor of arizona
[Applause]
joe biden joe was that a making fun of
his stutter do you guys think that was
making fun of biden's stutter
would lock us down or does this guy
stutter biden would reduce your income
65 hundred dollars and joe biden would
make washington dc
estate and
and how many presidents of the united
states would protect arizona by talking
about what bernie sanders wants to do
here
by endorsing prop 208 wanting to raise
our taxes
77
so on november 3rd vote no on prop 208
and vote yes for donald trump and mike
pence
to go back to the white house
oh my god these lunatics
thank you doug he's a great governor
he's a great great governor what a job
he's done and you know what we're not
going to take her time or anything but
martha mcsally author she's saving your
second amendment
mother mcsally great great senator she's
got to go
hard she's been agreed we just call her
honey did he just like come here honey
and vote for martha mcsally save
your second amendment save your second
amendment
thank you linda i'll see you down here
thank you donald oh now he's kicking her
off i'll see you down there thank you
darling
oh my god he's a worker she's a great
fighter pilot i'll see you down there
darling some of the pilots they said she
was a great oh my god
so thank you martha thank you thank you
doug
we also have a congressional candidate
that they say is a star
in the making i've heard it from a lot
of people vote for brandon martin
where's brandon
brandon good luck man i hear it's going
going good
good thank you brandon brandon don't
come up here brandon stay down there
brandon you're gonna do great no no no
not over here not okay
really well under my administration we
built the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and now we're doing it again you know
it's make america great again right i
say
make america great again again again
again
we did it and now we had to do it again
it's all right
it's happening and it's happening much
faster it looks like a super v
in my first three years we increased
family income more than five
times the gains in all eight years
under the last administration think of
that five times more
in the first three years five times more
than
eight years he doesn't know what he's
talking about
that's not even believable it's not
believable yeah because it's a lie
hispanic american unemployment asian
american unemployment all reached
record lows the lowest in the history of
our samoan american unemployment
inuit american unemployment including
more than
1.5 million hispanic americans that's a
record and i'm doing very well in the
polls with hispanic americans but i
always like you and you always like me
the fake news just didn't know that our
policies are lifting up all americans of
every income
since the china virus we created 11.4
million american jobs it's a record too
but you lost 45 i mean okay
you know the unemployment rate normally
i wouldn't be happy about this right but
the unemployment rate a week ago hit 7.8
think of that now we were hearing 42
it's going to go to 42 it's going to go
to 44. it's going to go to 38.
7.8 and heading this way think of that
would you believe that normally i
wouldn't say it because we were at 3.4
3.5 the best moment was mother mcsally
but that's okay we'll be there soon
after the virus left china
we experienced the smallest contraction
of any major western country
and the fastest recovery anywhere in the
world
i'm going to have to fact check that out
[Applause]
and we've already cut the unemployment
rate in less than half
that's a fantastic thing under biden and
obama it took over three and a half
years for arizona
to regain 60 percent of the jobs lost in
the crisis
and we've done it in four months think
of that
and it wasn't our fault oh guys check
this out manufacturing production
is up 61 retail sales are up
excuse me 121 percent
oh god that means more than before the
pandemic
and automobile production nobody's going
to believe this one is up
350 since april
that is wild 350
i have a way that we can stop it elect
sleepy joe
no no you're for who has a 401k okay
yeah so if i told you that your 401ks
and you're all at record highs are very
close right
if i told you that your 401ks will be
cut in half and much worse than that
that's what's going to happen well we
would think you were lying
he's going to raise your taxes by four
or five times
and they're going to put on regulations
every company is going to say let's get
out of here
because i'll tell you the regulation
cuts which are more than anybody
than any administration's ever done the
regulation
cuts in their own way were more
important than the biggest tax cut in
the history of our country
thank you man as president i've been
delivering for
our incredible hispanic american
community like nobody has done before
i'm part of that community he's
delivered nothing to me safe
neighborhoods
and hispanic-owned small businesses
joe biden would wipe out your small
businesses with lockdowns and
regulations
you know he said the other day oh i'd
lock it down oh great that's thanks a
lot joe we appreciate it
and devastate your family biden said
he'd listen to the doctors
and foucher just said last night on 60
minutes he would not lock down unless it
was absolutely last resort
fund extreme late term abortion
and he'll let social extreme late term
abortion essentially doesn't exist it's
almost non-existent
a socialist country we will never have
it
we can't we won't have a conflict that's
why we're going to win a record share of
the hispanic vote this november
get out and vote get out and vote
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting foreign wars defending foreign
borders
but now we are finally protecting our
nation rebuilding our cities
we are protecting our borders you know
the wall is almost finished right
our southern border and by the way the
biggest beneficiary maybe happens to be
arizona that wall how good is the wall
the wall is almost finished before they
stop coming in
now they come in they come in legally
now the wall is great goes down deep and
it goes up high
deep wall and we're bringing our jobs
our factories our troops
back home in the usa where they belong
right
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border
in u.s history our southern border is
now and i want to thank mexico mexico
has right now 27 000 troops guarding our
border how about that
and we've built almost 400 miles of the
wall
we're averaging about is this story he
says mexico will pay is exactly what
border patrol wanted i said i'd like to
just put up
i just like to put up concrete plank
they said no sir
we got to have it this way sir sir we
gave them the ultimate
we gave them everything they wanted and
they're really happy and it's had a huge
impact
we've got the best we've got the best
border that we've ever had
and you know what you have a big chunk
of it right here and it's really
worked you have 200 miles they tell me
200 miles
200 miles i didn't even know you had
that's a lot of mileage you're not
paying a damn
cent for it either all compliments of
the federal government right remember
when nancy wait so is the federal
government paying or mexico's paid
two things don't get obsolete walls and
wheels right
everything else is obsolete you know
they developed a new chip yesterday in
about 15 minutes it's going to be
obsolete they developed a new computer
15 minutes
two things that will obsolete be
obsolete a wheel and a wall
remember the democrats they said no we
want drones we want drones trump giving
a very uh nuanced understanding of
moore's law here guys
no 200 miles of wall in arizona
and you got it all it it's all done joe
biden's party continues to attack
our incredible border agents and they
are more than half of whom happen to be
hispanic americans i know a lot of them
[Applause]
[Music]
am i right right the republican party
will always stand with the heroes of ice
and border patrol these are incredible
people they're doing an incredible job
my opponent's immigration plan is the
most all right guys so we've uh
i think seen enough of this i know many
people are starting to
there's a certain point when when the
audience drops about 10 15 percent
the chat slows down we're all getting
bored we've all seen enough of this and
this is a man many of us have already
voted
uh voted voted out at least individually
we've voted in order to remove him so
my coverage is going to end now remember
we have a new discord davidpakman.com
and if there is an earlier rally
tomorrow i may cover the rally
and then open up some phone lines but
our big stream
powerful stream uh extremely
strong stream that will not be
suppressed
will be thursday night starting a half
hour before the last debate between joe
biden and donald trump
i will see everybody then
you